we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is
listen I should I even introduced this
voicemail or should we play it and then
just react to it we can just play it
okay no introduction necessary listen to
this voicemail that came in and then we
can discuss yes seems that you condone
harassment of right-wing conservatives
at restaurants hating having a meal for
a couple of your programs you stay you
have no problem and I would just like to
ask you how would you like to feel if
some right-wing Patriots recognize you
as you were at a tempest restaurant and
they didn't like your show and it's the
rest and in caring you and your gay
lover Louis as you were eating right I'm
just wondering about that listen and I'm
sure you would be little upset so so mad
very sad about how you were being
treated so that was Troy York first of
all I guess calling as his normal
character he wasn't using his black
character Jamal from University Park he
wasn't using his Hispanic character
named I forget what it is Luis Gonzalez
I don't even remember what it was
so what Troy is saying is if I support
the harassment of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
at the red hen would I be upset if I and
my gay lover Lewis were harassed at a
restaurant and of course this completely
misses the point the question is what is
legal and what is not legal if my quote
gay lover Luis and I are harassed at a
restaurant or refused service because we
are perceived to be gay in a state that
includes sexual orientation as a
protected class that is against the law
political beliefs working for
Trump being a vile liar none of that is
protected so if Troy doesn't like the
law then Troy can go and lobby for the
changing of the law but the analogy he
makes is a ridiculous one and of course
it's riddled with the rampant homophobia
that we've come to expect from Troy York
but Sarah Huckabee Sanders views
republicanism and employment in the
Trump administration is simply not
protected full stop and I know you don't
like it Pat but you recognize that
there's no legal question here
whatsoever
oh absolutely if you want to try to make
political affiliation a protected status
go ahead try to do that I don't think it
should be necessarily but you can make
that argument you can make that case and
then go and try to get the law changed
we've got a great bonus show for you
today sign up for the bonus show two
ways become a member at WWE pakman.com
sign up on patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and you will get
instant access to today's bonus show